big announcement are you ready for it
big big big big big announcement
so i have been asked 1 000 times over
the past
few years why in the world are you in
california
like why why would daley wire stay in
california i mean this place
has turned into a hell hole all you do
all day long on the show is just
complain about how bad california's been
and the answer was that i've been in
california literally my entire life
except for a three-year stint when i was
at
harvard law school in boston aside from
that i've spent my entire life
in california and i love this state it's
a beautiful state it's a state with a
lot of culture and a lot of fun to it
it's it's a great place in terms of
activities
you got the beach nearby you got
disneyland and then
over time it just became a hell hole and
it has become a hell hole at this point
and so yesterday we here at the daily
wire announced that we are moving
the entire company to nashville so just
yesterday governor jerry brown former
governor of california from
1975 to 1983 and then again from 2011 to
he said where are you gonna go where are
you gonna go you can't you know okay you
you say the california's bad where are
you gonna go the answer is
we are going to nashville we are taking
the entire company and we are picking up
and we are leaving and we are putting
our headquarters
in nashville okay that is where the
company will now be located we're taking
all 75 of our jobs
and we're taking our tens of millions of
dollars in annual revenue and we are
moving
all of that outside the state of
california and this is specifically and
really only
due to the crappy governance of the
state it is not because
we are foreign to the state again i've
lived here my entire life my business
partner jeremy boring has been here for
20 years
my parents have been here longer than
i've been alive we're not doing it
because we dislike california because we
are newbies because we couldn't take the
heat
anything like that i've been here the
whole time we are leaving because this
place has become
so horribly governed that if you have
the means to get out
and if you have a company relying on you
and if you have employees who are lying
on you
you are going to leave we are but the
tip of the spear we are not the only
ones elon musk has already
decided to leave the state he'll
probably be taking a lot of employees
with him over time
joe rogan has already left the state we
are leaving the state as well
again we are taking 75 employees who are
based in california and we are moving we
have about 100 employees across the
country
and we are relocating to a state that is
not run like garbage
tennessee and now did my business
partner
and i did jeremy and i and caleb
robinson our other business partners did
we ever think that we were going to be
moving this company
to nashville no otherwise we wouldn't
have built up these big beautiful
studios here in los
angeles and employed a bunch of people
in los angeles and hilariously enough
when we
announced this to our employees we
thought okay a lot of people are going
to be very upset about it it turns out
far more of our employees are excited
about leaving
california then would be excited about
staying in california because this place
has become unlivable
not only is the rent too damn high
because of all of the garbage zoning
regulations here
but the quality of life here has
degraded radically
now i'll be honest with you i had a
tough time convincing my wife just to
leave california
okay and to be frank with you i'm gonna
be splitting my time in some different
places not just in nashville but
the fact is that trying to get my wife
to leave california
was not an easy task because she too has
spent a lot of her life in california
she lived in sacramento
and now she lives in l.a and she's been
in california for a very long time
and over the past two years she's looked
around and she said
okay i guess you're right and the reason
for that is perfectly obvious
between the city of los angeles deciding
that they were going to see the entire
city
to low-level criminality they're not
going to enforce the law they're not
going to keep the streets clean they're
not going to make it livable for me to
allow my children to play outside of our
front gate
without adult supervision between them
allowing the streets to become
incredibly dirty and dangerous because
here is the reality if i let my kids
walk around the neighborhood they will
stumble across two open needles
during the course of that walk because
the city has specifically told law
enforcement they can't do anything about
the rampant homelessness problem that
has plagued los angeles 66 000 homeless
people in l.a county
every single underpass in l.a has entire
living facilities for homeless people
this is not by the way sympathy to the
homeless many of whom
really need serious help they are drug
addicted or mentally ill
and the city has decided that in the
name of freedom they are going to allow
the suburbs to be overrun by this
homelessness problem that does affect
people who are paying their taxes
and between that between the fact that
they've decided to defund the cops
and move away from allowing the police
to do their jobs entirely
between the increased taxes and the
higher levels of crime
and the lower levels of cleanliness
between the fact that
god decided to plague the state with a
giant wildfire spate over the last
several years apparently
it's like i didn't need the help god
like i got it i got it i didn't need the
signs and the wonders to drive me from
california
and frankly i'm just hoping that when
michael moles looks back at california
as we make our way out that he turns
around he looks back and he immediately
turns into a pillar of salt like that is
my dream but
whether or not that happens we are
leaving and you're going to see more of
this
again you're going to see a lot of this
new york new jersey connecticut you're
going to see this
in la you're going to see this in san
francisco people are going to pick up
and they're going to leave and the
people who are most likely to leave are
the people who can afford to leave
let's be honest about this the people
who are going to get trapped in los
angeles are the people who are lower
middle class
because they don't have the wherewithal
to pick up and leave they don't get to
decide
honestly where their jobs take place as
the head of a company i get to decide
where we take our jobs
and we are excited to allow our people a
better living standard
moving to some place like nashville that
is not governed like garbage in a red
state
then forcing them to stay in a place
that is very difficult to raise children
and to live
but blue states for too long have
thought that they can govern as badly as
they want there will be no consequences
that's true to a point and then beyond
that point it is no longer true
we have reached the breaking point we
are leaving and so daily wire will see
you
in nashville